la ville actuellement est absolument
grise la couleur a toujours existé dans
la ville regarde au Moyen-âge les
porches des églises étaient peintes il y
avait toujours une animation colorée je
pense que la couleur est indispensable à
l'équilibre de la vie
[Musique]
humaine des murailles de l'utesse aux
vieilles ru du Moyen-Âge qui serpentent
encore dans toutes nos villes anciennes
aux échopes dont le côté vieill de
quelques poésie c'est tout un urbanisme
tout un art de construire et de vivre
qui s'est ajouté superposé au cours des
[Musique]
siècles ces rues construites à première
vue sans plan ressembl à des labyrinthes
qui favorisent la rencontre éveillent le
regard font cheminer
l'imagination Philippe Augus fut
semble-t-il le premier roi à s'occuper
de l'urbanisme de la cité et il avait
confié à Maurice
le soin de modifier le visage de Paris
avec la Monarchie de Juillet mais
surtout avec Osman et Napoléon I une
autre are allait s'ouvrir celle des
grands
travaux ceuxci nettoyèrent et
bouleversèrent une grande partie de la
capitale une doctrine nouvelle naissait
celle de la ligne droite du Grand
Boulevard des perspectives large et
impérial
[Musique]
on dit même qu'elles étaient destinées à
tirer plus aisément au canon sur les
manifestants c'est ainsi que la rue la
ruelle perdit peu à peu son caractère
familier familial pour devenir un espace
impersonnel pour une foule
[Musique]
anonyme ce qui rend les ces lieux d'
Osman épouvantable à habiter et à
parcourir c'est que justement il n'y a
pas d'arbre dans la dans la rue de reenn
il y a pas un arbre il y a pas un
relais la rue n'avait de charme que
d'être ce vis-à-vis de deux théâtres que
l'on longeait l'enfant voyait on
traversait la rue on traversait la rue à
force de voir des attractions tout au
long du chemin
donc il faudrait maintenant que la rue
qui n'a plus d'objet ou à moins qu'on
rétablisse des magasins tant qu'on en
rétablisse pas la rue en elle-même n'a
plus grande raison d'être je pense qu'on
pourrait maintenant la remplacer ce qui
a toujours été le cas d'ailleurs dans
les villes anciennes par des séries de
places c'est-à-dire des lieux assez clos
avec un arbre de banc qui fasse des
lieux de séjour successifs qui soi plus
Plô des relais plutôt que simplement des
défilés puisque aussi bien il n'y a plus
de raison de défiler long de mur qui ne
comporte plus que des des
appartements les arbres ne poussent pas
en un jour et puis l'anarchie de la
construction et le mauvais entretien des
bâtiments ont multiplié dans les villes
ses façades aveugles et ses murs lépreux
des tâches qui altèrent la beauté d'un
site d'un monument d'une ville tout
entière
aux États-Unis où l'art descend
facilement dans la rue les artistes se
sont déchaînés leurs œuvres sont
discutables peut-être c'est disent
certain du camouflage du trompeleœil
tout cela n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs mais la démarche n'est-elle
pas
[Musique]
intéressante
à Paris des tentatives timides encore
sont faites pour donner à quelques murs
à quelques palissad un peu plus de getté
d'autres imaginent des façades nouvelles
pour rompre la monotonie de la rue ainsi
varelli rue billard dans le 8e
arrondissement où cette œuvre très
contestée de la rue François 1 ou cet
immeuble peint par l'architecte moine
rue
saint-lazar tout cela correspond aux
idées que veulent promouvoir les
artistes d'une nouvelle association le
mur
animé celui-là a été fait en 1971 et
c'est le premier qui a été réalisé à
Paris et depuis il y en a eu deux trois
autres mais malheureusement il y a
beaucoup de murs qu'ils sont salubres et
sans fenêtres et qui pourrait faire de
très très beaux supports comme celui-ci
pour être donné à un artiste
contemporain alors que nous sommes sur
le plateau Beaubourg qui va être d'ici à
peine 6 mois le centre international et
mondial de l'art contemporain quels sont
les obstacles principaux principalement
les autorisations auprès des
municipalité et surtout des beauards les
beauards aussi oui les beauards euh
auraiit tendance à vouloir concevoir les
villes telles qu'elles ont été conçues
mais ne pas du tout promouvoir l'ARM
moderne dans les villes les beauard ont
sans doute quelques raisons d'être
prudents toutefois les peintures et
dessins imaginés par les artistes du mur
animé valent la peine d'être regardé à
vous de
[Musique]
juger une des choses les plus
intéressantes dans le mur peint c'est
d'abord introduire la couleur dans la
viille parce que je crois que la ville
actuellement est absolument grise la
couleur a toujours existé dans la ville
regarde au Moyen-âge les portes des
églises étaient peintes les maisons
avaient offrit par les matériaux par les
les le bois les pierres les ardoises il
y avait toujours une animation colorée
je pense que la couleur est
indispensable à l'équilibre de la vie
humaine et actuellement la la ville est
devenue noire est devenue grise est
devenue triste alors le murpin peut
introduire beaucoup de choses dans la
ville premièrement le rêve l'humour et
l'art la mode est venue un peu trop
brutalement et souvent ce sont des
peintures trop passagères il faut que la
peinture est un intérêt quelconque je
CITIS il y a beaucoup de de de maisons
comme ça à la Renaissance qui étaient
peintes également soit avec des objets
soit simplement avec des fausses
fenêtres parce que c'était le l'utilité
de l'architecture d'avoir des fausses
fenêtres ce qui rendait la façade
charmante et vivante et surprenante
d'être comme ça un trompeeleœil souvent
dit il serait bon de se défouler dans la
rue et de dessiner sur les murs non tout
finirait d'ailleurs plutôt par des obs
dessiné et en plus il n'y a pas de
raison qu'on se défoule soi-même en
obérant l'autre c'est l'autre qui voit
qui est qui est
responsable donc il ne faut pas de la il
ne faut pas de complaisance dans ces
sortes de
chos pas de complaisance en effet on ne
peut pas dire qu'Émile a l'auteur de
l'ensemble de la grande borneag en
est-tu avec le coloriste Fabio reti il a
voulu composer ville en couleur où l'œil
de l'homme permet à tout endroit où il
se déplace d'avoir une vue de la cité
dont l'image globale lui échappe
[Musique]
toujours
à é ville nouvelle de la région
parisienne c'est au coloriste et
plasticiens Bernard lassu candro et para
les architectes de cet ensemble
d'immeubl pyramide ont demandé de
réfléchir à l'image que ces habitant
pourrai avoir de leur ville Bernard
lassu a déjà conçu de nombreux ensembles
coloré France l'expérience mérite aussi
un regard
[Musique]
attentif mais il s'agit pas uniquement
d'ailleurs d'apparence au sens visuel du
terme si nous prenons une image l'homme
de la campagne ou simplement aujourd'hui
le chasseur qui va dans la campagne ça
satisfa action c'est peut-être d'avoir
un sol extrêmement varié il va traverser
un chume il va marcher dans un bois de
pain il va s'appuyer sur sur un sol doux
il va traverser une rivière il va se
éventuellement se mer un peu les pieds
il avait donc des contacts sensoriels
extrêmement diversifiés avec le sol bon
si vous prenez la plupart des villes
d'aujourd'hui et bien c'est le macadam
et uniquement le maadam et ceci
indiqueon a tendance à se réfugier du
fait de cette disparition de phénomènes
tactiles par exemple dans le domaine vis
alors on a l'impression qu'on pourrait
résoudre une espèce d'absence de
présence
sensorielle par exemple tactile
uniquement par des par des phénomènes
visuels ce que nous essayons
actuellement c'est
d'organiser un champ sensible simplement
de retrouver un certain nombre de présen
sensibles qui existaient dans des
contextes ruraux ou autres finalement
toutes ces sensations que vous voulez
essayer de retrouver de réinsérer dans
dans la ville que ce n'était pas dans le
temps la rue qui les
donnait vous savez c'est je crois qu'il
faut être un peu prudent en ce qui
concerne la rue nous dirons
que que nous avions peut-être en ce qui
concerne les modenatures architecturales
les couleurs une certaine
diversification que nous tentons depuis
des années de réintroduire dans
l'apparence du
bâti et justement ce que je voudrais
indiquer c'est
que une espèce de
pseudoationalisation
pseudoationalité de la construction a
amené à penser que l'apparence de la
construction devait non pas être
utilisée pour l'animation de la rue mais
devait être utilisé pour expliquer la
construction du bâtiment et il y a eu là
me semble-t-il une grave erreur
d'interprétation pouvez me donner un
exemple le fait par exemple de dire je
vais montrer qu'une maison est
construite en béton et et en métal et de
bien dissocier la structure en métal de
celle en béton par exemple en la
peignant en rouge était simplement une
organisation visuelle faite pour montrer
le principe de construction donc c'est
un problème d'architecture c'est lié à
un bâtiment mais c'est pas un phénomène
de rue un phénomène urbain et justement
on a trop tendance à penser par objet et
non pas par ensemble vous n'êtes pas le
maquilleur de l'architecture c'est un
terme horrible et c'est un terme
profondément faux dans la mesure
justement où il n'est pas question de
maquiller quoi que ce soit et
l'apparence nous devons choisir une
forme aux apparences c'est à nous de la
choisir mais nous en sommes totalement
libres en réalité l'apparence c'estàdire
la forme la forme ça n'a jamais été la
réalité du bâtiment ça réalité physique
c'est l'impression que vous en avez la
forme c'est ce que les psychologues nous
ont appris c'est qu'il n'y avait pas
identité entre l'apparence et la
présence physique donc à partir du
moment où il y a dissociation entre
l'apparence et la présence physique nous
pouvons utiliser l'apparence en
particulier pour créer une présence
sensible de la rue mais tant qu'on
refuse cela au nom justement du
maquillage on ne peut pas animer la
rue si nous comprenons bien le propos de
Monsieur Bernard lassu qui imagine
l'environnement visuel de la ville d'évr
ce n'est pas tellement l'œil qui compte
mais les
travers cet il nous ressentons ce n'est
pas tant la forme de la ville qui compte
que l'idée qu'on s'en fait à chacun son
interprétation c'est bien tout le
problème de l'art quand nous savons
combien l'œil est sensible 1000 fois
plus que les autres sens estime un
spécialiste américain ARD on comprend
l'importance de
[Musique]
l'apparence on a égaré beaucoup
l'urbanisme contemporain à
un prospect de 100 m avec de l'herbe et
le bonheur non c'est la solitude et
plutôt le
désespoir ce qui est surtout désespérant
c'est que ce genre de villeel ne pourra
peut-être jamais être animé ni même
[Musique]
réanimer